In Islam, a woman is financially
secured.
She does not have to work for a living,
she's financially secured as compared to
the man. In Islam,
a woman before she is married, it is the
duty of her father and her brother. And
after she's married, it is the duty of a
husband and a son to look after all
financial aspects, whether it be
lodging, bathing, clothing, everything.
She's financially secured. She does not
have to work even for a small bit of it.
So in Islam, a woman is financially
secured.
But
if a Muslim woman, if a Muslim woman
wants to work
with her own free will, she can
as long as the work she's doing is
within the purview of the Islamic
Sharia. It's a permissible work.
And if she works, she's entitled for
equal pay that which a man gets. Unlike
the western world, if you see in America
today,
if you analyze the statistics for the
same post,
man and woman in the same company,
normally a man gets paid more. Even
today
in Islam, a woman need not work. But if
she wants to work willingly,
no one can force her to work. But if she
wants to work, she can work and she's
entitled for equal pay. But natural she
cannot do work which exhibits a body
like modeling,
dancing, film acting. Many work which is
prohibitive for the woman is even
prohibitive for the man like working in
alcoholic bar, serving alcohol, working
in a gambling den,
working in a conventional bank which is
based on ribbon interest.
Both men and women cannot work here.
They cannot work in a company which is
dealing with corruption which is
involved in bribery.
So all these types of work are
prohibited for both men and women.
In Islam, no one can force her to work.
But if she wants to work willingly, she
can work. If she's married, it should be
with the permission of the husband.
She can very well
do business
as long as when she does business it is
through a maram maybe husband, father,
son. And we have a beautiful example
of hazat khadijah may Allah be pleased
with her. She was a business woman very
successful and she did business through
her husband the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
We want our women folk to be teachers,
to be nurses, to be gynecologists, to be
pediatricians,
to be doctors. They can do work even at
home. Maybe stitching, maybe embroidery,
maybe basket making, a variety.
And whatever she earns, she need not
give it to any of her family members.
She can keep it for herself, even for
her food. Yet if she's not married, it
is the duty of the father and the
brother. After she's married, it's the
duty of the husband and son to look
after her. Even if she earns, no one can
tell, okay, now you're earning, you
contribute to the family. If she wishes,
she can. It's her will.
Even if she's rich and if the husband is
poor, yet it's the duty of the husband
to look after her lodging, clothing,
bloating, all financial aspect. In
Islam, a woman is financially secured.
When she gets married, Allah says in the
Quran in surah Nisah 4 verse number
four, give to the woman
a marital gift, adore, a mah. So when
she gets married, she gets mad.
In most of the society especially in
India where I come from, it is opposite.
It is a husband who takes dowi
from the wouldbe wife.
And depending upon his status maybe if
he's a graduate he may ask for 500,000
rupees. If he's the engineer he may ask
for 2 million rupees 20 lakh rupees. If
he's a doctor he may ask for 5 million
rupees 50 lakh rupees as the herds and
cles are being sold in the marketplace.
But this is common. It is also happening
in the Muslim Indian society.
You know they may give Mah for names
sake 500 rupees 786 rupees you can't
even buy a pair of shoes with that money
so they keep Mah for names sake 786
rupees